tengo una ecuación muy simple escrita
por aquí a más b igual hace y lo que
quiero que pensemos es que si sabemos
que es un número entero así que digamos
que por aquí pongo los números enteros
déjenme hacer por aquí a mi conjunto de
los números enteros y voy a escribirlo
aquí
pero sí voy a suponer que a es un número
entero así que vive por aquí voy a poner
por aquí
e imagina que también ve es un entero
por lo tanto me puede ser el mismo
entero que puede ser uno distinto pero
para que se distinga a dv
voy a poner por aquí avn por aquí tengo
a b y b también es un número entero y mi
pregunta va a ser ok cuando sumamos
estos dos números enteros estaremos
seguros de que vamos a obtener otro
número entero es decir podemos asegurar
que ese también va a ser un número
entero y te encargo que pausa es el
vídeo y pienses un poco en esto y al
hacerlo puedes usar algunos ejemplos de
esta suma para poder averiguarlo no sé
podrás pensar qué va
no sé supongamos que también vale uno y
entonces en este caso se valdría dos que
también es un número entero pero mi
pregunta es siempre pasar a esto así que
es momento de que pausa es el vídeo
bueno pues la respuesta es que si hay
varias formas de probarlo pero no voy a
entrar mucho en esos detalles por ahora
lo que sí quiero decirte es que cuando
tú tienes una situación así es decir
cuando tú tomas dos elementos de un
conjunto en este caso dos elementos de
los números enteros y le aplicas una
operación en este caso de operaciones la
suma siempre que obtengas un resultado
que nos dé un elemento del mismo
conjunto ojo recuerda que a bien el
resultado podría ser a o podría ser b o
algún otro elemento distinto del
conjunto así que vamos a ponerlo por
aquí voy a poner por aquí hace voy a
poner por aquí hacer para que nos encima
con ninguno de los otros dos así que
pensemos en un elemento distinto y bueno
siempre que tengas este caso en donde
tenemos una operación que en este caso
es la suma y se le aplicamos a dos
elementos del conjunto
el resultado está en el conjunto es
decir te quedas en el conjunto en este
caso se vive en el conjunto porque es un
elemento de él una forma de pensarlo es
que éste va a ir a dar justo por acá
este también porque estamos aplicando la
operación suma cuando ves una situación
de esta forma decimos que este conjunto
en este caso el conjunto de los números
enteros es cerrado bajo la suma y es más
déjeme escribirlo en este caso el
conjunto con
de los números enteros de los enteros en
ceros es cerrado bajo la suma
cerrado un ser raro bajo la suma bajo
zuma
y esta palabra ha cerrado o cerradura es
el concepto general es más déjame
escribirlo por aquí
a dura y este concepto cerradura puede
ser que lo hayas escuchado en sus cursos
de bachillerato o tal vez en algún curso
de matemáticas de un nivel superior
puede ser que pienses que es un concepto
bastante avanzado pero lo único que está
diciendo es lo siguiente tú tienes una
operación la cual puedes aplicar a
elementos de un conjunto y además cada
vez que aplicas la operación a todos los
elementos del conjunto obtienes otro
elemento de ese mismo conjunto es decir
te quedas en el conjunto entonces es
cuando decimos que el conjunto es
cerrado bajo la operación en este caso
bueno la operación fue la suma y por eso
hablamos de cerrado bajo la suma y bueno
también te puedes preguntar acerca de
otro tipo de operaciones por ejemplo
serán a déjame ponerlo así es el
conjunto de los números enteros
de los
enteros será cerrado se ha cerrado bajo
y vamos a pensar si el conjunto de los
números enteros es cerrado bajo primero
la multiplicación
team
la canción después pensemos en la
división
vamos a pensar también en la división de
sión y pensemos también en la resta voy
a bajar un poco esta pantalla y pensemos
también en la resta en la resta
era el conjunto de los números enteros
cerrados bajo la multiplicación bajo la
división o bajo la resta y es momento de
que pau self vídeo y también pienses en
esto así que en manos a la obra pensemos
primero en la operación multiplicación
si tú tomas dos enteros y los
multiplicas bueno de hecho siempre vas a
obtener otro número entero entonces el
conjunto de los números enteros ese rato
bajo la multiplicación en este caso es
cierto y ahora qué pasa con la división
bueno es bastante sencillo probar el
caso en el cual tomamos la división de
dos números enteros y no obtenemos un
número entero por ejemplo hagamos uno
simple
imagínate que vale 11 entre 2 bueno en
este caso tanto el uno como el dos
números enteros y si los dividimos que
me va a dar bueno me va a dar un medio y
este no es un número entero así que si
este es el conjunto de mis números
enteros por acá puedo tener al conjunto
de los números racionales dejarlo así
tengo a los racionales recuerda que todo
número entero es racional pero no todo
número racional es entero este de aquí
entonces date cuenta que un medio es
número racional estaríamos en este caso
tenemos por aquí al 1 tenemos por aquí
al 2 y cuando aplicamos la operación
división entonces nos salimos de este
conjunto y llegamos al un medio que es
un número irracional algún medio que
estaría por aquí así que nos salimos del
conjunto de los números enteros tenemos
algo que no es entero pero es un número
racional entonces el conjunto de los
números enteros no es cerrado bajo la
división y la resta claro y de nuevo no
voy a hacer una prueba rigurosa pero al
tomar cualesquiera dos enteros al restar
los vas a obtener de nuevo un número
entero el objetivo en general es darte
una breve introducción a la noción de
cerradura cerradura es un concepto clave
es decir la idea de que si tú tienes un
conjunto
y si le aplicas una operación a ese
conjunto y siempre obtienes un elemento
de ese conjunto entonces ese conjunto es
cerrado bajo esa operación no importa
cuál sea el conjunto que tomes en este
caso estamos tomando los números enteros
y hablamos de bueno la suma la
multiplicación la división y la resta
pero no sé podrás pensar en cualquier
otro conjunto
por ejemplo el conjunto de los
polinomios y ver si es cerrado bajo la
suma que en efecto lo es o pensar en el
conjunto de los racionales y pensar si
son cerrados bajo la operación
exponencia ción en fin puedes pensar
muchos casos pero espero que esto te dé
una buena idea de lo que significa el
concepto de cerradura y de lo que
significa el concepto de que un conjunto
sea cerrado bajo alguna operación